well it's not very good is it
hermione granger will forever be emma
watson in our minds
but emma has also established herself as
a brilliant actress and
activist outside of harry potter you'd
think playing such a beloved character
for an entire decade would pigeonhole an
actor but emma watson has managed to
break out of that box
by focusing on her education activism
and choosing diverse and interesting
film roles
here are the emma watson roles you
totally overlooked
when everyone can be found we can never
lose
a friend one of the things we admire
most about emma watson is that she knows
when to take a break
back in 2016 emma took a year-long break
from acting to focus on reading and
personal growth
even starting her own feminist book club
on goodreads after releasing two movies
in 2017
she pressed pause again emma finally
returned to the big screen in 2019 as
meg march
in greta gerwig's academy award-winning
adaptation of little
women alongside powerhouse actresses
like sercia ronan
florence pew laura dern and meryl streep
meg
is the most traditional of the march
sisters but emma brings a subtlety to
the performance
which goes to show she's only gotten
better and better over time despite the
hiatus from acting
just because my dreams are different
than yours doesn't mean they're
unimportant
in one of her first post-potter roles
emma played sam
in the perks of being a wallflower where
she starred opposite logan lerman's
sweet shy charlie
this coming of age drama showed that she
could break out and do something totally
different
the possibilities for how emma would
follow up harry potter were
infinite but so was the pressure that's
one reason why emma chose to chop off
her long locks after harry potter
wrapped the actress said she did it
because she needed a drastic change
and perks proved to be the perfect
follow-up by showcasing that emma could
do serious
and dramatic but still fun no magic
involved
innocent you may have forgotten this gem
of a role in this is the end
the apocalyptic comedy from the minds of
seth rogen and evan goldberg
emma played a character so unexpected
you wouldn't believe it
herself in this hilarious end of the
world comedy
fictionalized versions of the cast must
reckon with the end of the world
emma played an exaggerated version of
herself trying to survive the end times
while she doesn't have too much screen
time she absolutely steals the show when
a misunderstanding leads her to turn on
her friends
to go fend for herself who knew emma had
such a knack for comedic timing
maybe it's just the incongruity of
seeing the put together actress in
survival mode
but she absolutely nails the funny in
this role i mean no
but i would say it's completely obvious
what's
one of emma watson's more overlooked
roles is nicki moore
in the bling ring directed by sophia
coppola the satirical movie based on
real events got pretty mixed reviews but
it's one of emma's most
interesting roles because it's so
different from anything else she's done
here we see emma transformed into a
vapid image obsessed valley girl who
spends her days robbing the homes of
celebrities like paris hilton and
lindsay lohan
in an interview with gq watson said that
nikki is
everything i felt strongly against she's
superficial materialistic vain and
immoral
that's why it was such a great role for
her because it showed the world what she
could really do as an actress
this has been a very difficult time for
myself
next up darren aronofsky's noah based on
the tale of noah and the ark this
biblical epic saw emma playing noah's
adopted daughter-in-law
isla she was also reunited with perk's
co-star logan lerman
although this time she plays a love
interest to douglas booth's
shem the movie had an all-star cast in
russell crowe
jennifer connolly anthony hopkins and
ray windstone
emma gives a heart-wrenching performance
in what ends up being a complicated tale
about morality
and mercy he chose you for a reason noah
moving away from the ancient epic of
noah we come full circle to
the circle a techno thriller that
focuses on a google-like tech company
with mysterious and potentially
dangerous plans
this high-profile critical flop came out
in 2017
and was based on a novel of the same
name by dave eggers
starring next to tom hanks emma played
the role of may holland
an employee of the circle who gets
involved in a mysterious one-of-a-kind
experiment that changes her life
and the lives of those around her while
the movie was a flop emma keeps
surprising with interesting film choices
what i am proposing is radical openness
and unbroken connection like this next
one
in 2015 emma starred in colonia also
known as the colony in the uk
colonia is a historical thriller that's
inspired by true events
set during the 1973 military coup in
chile the movie focuses on emma watson's
lena
a young woman who gets caught up in an
eerie and dangerous cult called the
colonia dignidad
in order to save her boyfriend daniel we
love seeing emma play the unlikely hero
swept up in events beyond her control
i've been searching for god but i
haven't found him yet
emma played angela gray in the twisty
psychological thriller
regression starring ethan hawk and harry
potter's david thwellis
who you may know better as remus lupin
said in 1990
the movie is a dark examination of abuse
the panic surrounding demonic cults
and repressed memory emma plays the teen
daughter of the main suspect at the
center of the case but spoiler alert
her character isn't quite who she seems
at first and it makes for an interesting
and unexpected performance from emma
watson
you walk around as if
everything was normal emma's voice has
become super recognizable so it makes
sense she do voice work at some point or
another
but thus far she's only dipped her toes
into voice acting
once in her career did you know that
emma starred in the animated movie the
tale of despereaux
in 2007 in between harry potter films
emma took the time to voice princess pea
in this animated adaptation of kate
dicamillo's children's book the tale of
despereaux
in the movie emma plays the young
princess who befriends despereaux a
brave mouse who embraces adventure
instead of running from it is that you
my little mouse while her big name and
star power has meant that emma is often
playing the lead
she has also done some understated work
in supporting roles like this one
emma played a small supporting role as
lucy in my week with marilyn which stars
michelle williams as the iconic marilyn
monroe
the movie follows an aspiring filmmaker
who bonds with marilyn while she spends
a week shooting a film in london
while emma only spent a few days
shooting her scenes she got to share
screen time with eddie redmayne
years before he would join the wizarding
world as newt scamander
and now it's time to search the sites a
little higher
and speaking of harry potter connections
way back in 2007
emma starred in ballet shoes a
television movie based on the 1936 novel
of the same name
she plays pauline fossil one of three
orphans adopted by an eccentric explorer
played by richard griffiths
who struggled to pursue their ambitious
dreams you may recognize griffiths as
uncle dursley himself this one is
especially notable because it was emma
watson's very first role
outside of playing hermione anyone who
goes off any audition anywhere has to
sing dance from
sight who knew that on top of being a
wonderful actress
model activist we could go on that emma
watson could also
sing she makes the perfect bell in
disney's live action version
of beauty and the beast her most
commercially successful
film since harry potter beauty and the
beast showed us yet another side of emma
watson
and yes that's actually her singing
while she said the experience of singing
was
unexpected and terrifying she rose to
the occasion
that and reinventing a beloved disney
princess make for a lot of pressure
but emma took the challenge in stride
and the movie was a huge success
i'm not sure they mean it as a
compliment emma has stuck mostly to
movies over her career but she had a
cameo appearance on a long-running
british sitcom called the vicar of
dibley
the show originally ran from 1994 to
1998 but has returned for a number of
specials
including the bbc comic relief special
in which emma appeared in 2015.
looks like this is the end gave emma a
taste for comedy because she
kills it as reverend iris making subtle
jabs at lead character geraldine granger
as they compete for the position of
bishop you may recognize geraldine as
actress dawn french
who played the fat lady in harry potter
and the prisoner of azkaban
they have to choose just one of us and
last but certainly not least emma watson
is the star she is because of her
career-making start in the harry potter
franchise at the age of nine
she's come a long way since her time is
the lovable bookworm hermione granger
it's easy to see emma only through the
lens of hermione but in the years since
harry potter ended
we've seen her do it all and make a real
impact on the world in other important
ways
but we'll never forget the role that
started it all there's no doubt that
emma watson perfectly embodied the
brains and bushy hair that we all know
and love in hermione
and that hermione would never have been
the same without emma watson
so a genius like dumbledore couldn't
possibly be fooled by a daughter's
pathetically dim-witted
emma watson may have gotten her start as
hermione but she's grown into a
versatile
and talented star did any of these other
roles of hers surprise you
drop a comment below and don't forget to
hit that subscribe button for more
videos from the things
thanks for watching